well what i'm hearing too is that um
you know i when you show up for yourself
it's it's basically like
when you don't put yourself first it's
basically self-abandonment
and so hit me in the heart yeah and i
doubt i've dealt with this too
like in my own way with my own things
where i
would do the same i would show up and
show up in other ways
other than for myself and that
self-abandonment ends up becoming
you know a real problem and then it
creates codependency issues
and so oh my god right am i saying all
the trigger words right so
yeah stuff that i still am working on
every day you know i
i'm with you and you know it manifests
in different ways but
when you know the selfish that we're
calling it that's uh
you know i had this conversation with my
mom actually because i had to do with my
mom the stuff
the abandonment stuff and um and you
know mom kind of abandoned me
on an emotional level so then in
relationships i would abandon myself
in an emotional way and and abandon
myself completely and serve other people
and that just is going to lead to bad
things and bad partners
and um so she
said she was saying literally the word
selfish she's like
that sounds like if i do that it sounds
selfish and i'm like
no it's like when you learn how to show
up for yourself you say yes to yourself
which get
then allows other people you can show up
for other people the same way we can't
meet we can only meet someone at the
level that we're
at so if you abandon yourself that's the
kind of
way you're going to show up for people
so when you don't abandon yourself you
don't abandon your friends
and it's just it's very reciprocal it's
really the universe showing you
you and um so that's like
badass that you figured that out i think
that um
i i you know there's another thing that
i had heard you heard said it was um
with your your best friend machine gun
kelly and it was something he said i
wrote it down he said
um taught you how to remain self-aware
but
outside of yourself and i was like that
is such a
deep sentence can you explain
what that means to you yeah i mean there
is
so much power in zooming out right
um standing in a room
looking in the mirror you see yourself
you're looking and
you're staring directly into what is
presented in front of you
there is so much power in zooming out
like i want to be able to understand
i want to see myself you know as as a
songwriter
just in general i have found out
that like the world sees you very
differently than you see yourself
and like you can learn so much
from zooming out and trying to see
yourself through someone else's lens
right it's it's like we are we are
obviously individuals and we are seeing
the world through
our lens almost every second of the day
to actually stop and be like you know
that that's why i bring up songwriting
because like i write songs for other
people and i like to have songs
of my own i like to write with other
people and it's such this crazy thing
that working with someone they could
write
the song that defines you better than
you can because they see you
how the world sees you and it's like
when you're force-feeding the world i am
this i am that i am this i am that
it's like the only true sentence is i am
so anything
that you put after i am this you're
lying you don't know you don't know all
you know is that you are
right and i am is the only true
statement you can say
everything that comes after that is
you kind of just talking about yourself
like a way that isn't actually always
digestible and like i've had such
a journey of trying to figure out how to
you know a lot of a lot of artists think
that the word like
relatable is like the devil right it's
like oh
then you're like losing your artistry or
you're you're dumbing down
it's like i want to be relatable
i want the world to be able to relate to
me and if i'm acting out of this i'm
one of one and no one else is like me
it's like you're losing this
empatheticness and like i i was raised
by two women
right like i didn't have a father figure
in my life and like what these women did
for me
was allow me to say like i'll never
forget
my mom took me to my the first movie i
ever saw i went to a theater
we watched the movie stepmom right and
my mom
is relating to this movie on such a
hardcore level because it's about
dealing with like a single mom situation
and i'm sitting here and she's not
crying and i'm like this six-year-old
crying my eyes up
and had my father have been next to me
he might have gone hey
toughen up my mom's going
yes you know like i'm getting a vocal
talking about it
i was planted with this seed of being in
touch
with empathy and putting yourself into
someone else's position
i can almost see the world through
someone else's eyes better than i can
see it through my home
i can almost feel for other people more
than i can feel for myself
i would almost take i would almost take
that any day
being able to go you know what i i'm
confused as [ __ ] but i understand you
you know and and i think like that's one
of those things
it's like this this great duality you
know speaking of machining on kelly like
one thing that
that we go back and forth on like the
the simplest way to put it is like we we
do a lot of like
filming stuff directing stuff and stuff
like that together and like
let's say there's someone sitting on a
chair in the middle of the room
you know my mind is going everything
around that person is the art and his
mind is going
no the person is the art and i'm like
okay i get it i see what you're saying
but i also see what i'm saying and we're
gonna we're gonna meet in the middle and
create something that's
actually this duality of like coming
outside yourself so like
i love to be self-aware and understand
like my
brand i love to understand my brand
better than anyone
i love to to know myself better than
someone else i love that
but at the same time like i can jump
inside someone else's skin
so quickly and understand what people
are going through and i will be
the first to be open with the emotion of
like
feeling on a really really extra level
and and that's why i love like the idea
of being like
i had to understand that
i'm gonna put myself first i am
and while doing that you learn all these
other tools
about how to actually communicate with
people properly like communication has
always been like this thing that's just
like
a constant struggle for me you know i
i i shoot myself in the foot a lot not
being able to communicate properly with
people
or expecting people to understand
right away where i'm coming from you
know and i've ruined so
many relationships by communicating
improperly
and figuring out how to walk that line
between
knowing and not knowing like i love the
sentence the only thing that we really
know
is we know nothing at all i love that
sentence but i'm also like [ __ ] you bro
i'm [ __ ] 34 years old and if i don't
know [ __ ] by now then what the [ __ ] am i
doing here
right so i'ma walk that line right down
the middle that's like i know nothing
and i know everything
so meet me in the middle and we can have
a conversation